[Musique]
bonjour les enfants je vous présente ti
homm il veut grandir il veut apprendre
son alphabet vous aussi vous vous avez
envie d'apprendre l'alphabet avec
tititsomme nous allons ouvrir son livre
et entrer dans la forêt des lettres ah
comme abeille bonjour
abeille abeille de ma fat araignée des
Avirons bonne année Amalia Aicha roule
et s maloya jusqu'à l'aurore
cette petite abeille danses mal a
S Au revoir abeille B de Babou bonjour
Babou Babou botte bleue avance boum boum
boum gros ballot de brocard sur la tête
bon courage Babou mais où va-t-il ce
Babou gros ballot sur la tête boum boum
boum c'est comme cabri bonjour cabri
cabri
dansos COC coco Canel cabri dans carocan
cras calouilé cabri dans la case chante
canmapou coco canmapou canmapou canou
dou canmou canmou canou est doux au
revoir
cabri d comme dodo bonjour dodo DOD dans
sa dentelle ça va deux doigts aussi la
lune veille jusqu'à demain sur le
berceau et
Dango joue pour la diva une douce
berceuse do dos l'enfant dos l'enfant
dormira bien vite do dos l'enfant d'au
l'enfant
dormira
bientôt au revoir
dodo eu comme
endormi bonjour endormi
endormi dit Émilie la lune luit dans
l'eucalyptus et les étoiles freedonne la
romance des bébés fais à me les yeux
jusqu'à
demain bonne nuit
bonne nuit les
étoiles te gardent bonne nuit bonne nuit
ferme les yeux jusqu'à
demain au revoir endormi
dor F comme fourmi bonjour
fourmi fourmi di phasila
fourmi au feu au feu le farfare brûle
mais va chez chz l' chez Flor dans sa
cuisine on coule le café point
final Antonia moule ton café Tonia
Antonia moule ton café nous va boire un
coup Antonia moule ton café Tonia
Antonia moule ton café Nou va boire un
coup au revoir
fi j'ai comme gecko bonjour gecko gecko
de grandtilette et gourment lundi il se
gaveave de
goyavier mardi me direz-vous bien mardi
il déguste des grains de
galaberre mon gars dit grenouille
attention mange un petit
guigine au revoir Geo de
[Musique]
grandtilett